we get here for about half five let the
shop bring the papers in from the back
and start making the news rounds for the
paper boys deliveries sandwiches time
just goes before you know it's ten
eleven twelve o'clock most of the work
is dealing with customers having a chat
with some of them
last time we just keep all the shell
stucked up get the shop tidy make a note
of things that are need replacing so
that when we go to the patient area we
know what to get more of a topic than
anything else being a newsagent
you know it has its ups and downs and
one of the downsides is that you have to
work long hours we have to wake up early
every morning normally that's not a
problem but sometimes it can be
difficult to wake up we bought what the
business in 2004 and for the first four
or five years trade was very good it's
just getting difficult less people are
buying newspapers the younger generation
tend to read online the older generation
they gain old and unfortunately some of
them are dying this is the good old
fashioned shop keeping back to basics
you know how it should be how it has
been then the modern-day version of open
or Larry we quite like that interaction
face to face she doesn't really have
much family and she regards us as her
family so I should come and sit down and
have a little chat with us it makes it
feel better
yeah she dumped me here for me as well
one time she's very you know she sort of
treats us like her kids I'm going not
they go away happier which makes you
happy so which is very satisfying this
is not see you tomorrow you right here I
think I don't like the most is that it's
seven days a week
it's 364 days of the year
when we first have the shop I we used to
have one day off now I've doubled that
and you leave I have Boxing Day Off as
well so I just I don't like the fact
that I only get two days off in the
whole year if I if I could have a week
off that won't perfect for me
overall it's okay I wouldn't knock it
too much
you